entrer en soins intensifs, c'est-à-dire le
type de soins sérieux que vous pouvez
recevoir, les soins intensifs sont destinés aux patients les plus
malades, ce qui n'est pas fait par
mesure de précaution, il est peut-être allé
à l'hôpital par mesure de précaution,
mais il serait allé en
soins intensifs parce que  ils s'inquiètent de l'
état de sa santé
et elle a eu kovat 19 min a déjà
récupéré et pourtant nous l'avons considérée
comme étant plus vulnérable il a été malade pendant
sept jours puis il a commencé à s'aggraver
par les bruits des choses la plupart du temps  les
patients dont je me suis occupé dans la
communauté leur température a augmenté au
sixième ou septième jour, certains pouvant durer
plus longtemps, mais c'est toujours une sorte de
drapeau rouge pour nous de poser la question est-ce que cela
s'aggrave réellement est-ce que cette
maladie grave est là  quelque chose d'autre se passe
parce que la majorité des cas, les cas,
nous continuerons à parler de la maladie légère à
modérée, ces personnes iront
mieux et n'auront pas de température
au septième jour